[Music]
what if we lost our entire atmosphere
all at once
let's say the earth's magnetic field
took a break and allowed strong solar
winds to come and strip away our
protective space blanket would earth
instantly turn into a big lifeless rock
would you still be able to breathe
could our atmosphere ever come back
this is what if and here's what would
happen if our atmosphere vanished into
thin air
just how important is the atmosphere to
our planet
it's absolutely vital it protects us
from asteroids and solar radiation it
regulates our climate it makes life on
earth possible
our nearest neighbor mars lost most of
its atmosphere some 4 billion years ago
and look what's become of it once warm
and wet it ain't the planet it used to
be
its atmosphere hasn't vanished
completely there's still a very thin
layer left but have you ever heard of
any life found on mars
what exactly would happen to earth when
the atmosphere went away
[Music]
well it's far from a happy ending
take away the earth's atmosphere and
suddenly it would become very very quiet
you wouldn't hear a thing
that's because sound waves are actually
vibrations in the air
but no air no sound
there's no sound in space the star wars
universe just isn't accurate
the sky would turn black because there
would be no particles in the air to
scatter the blue light of sunshine
planes would plummet to the ground and
birds
they need air pressure to support them
as they fly
oceans lakes and rivers would start
acting weird as well
with no atmospheric pressure the boiling
point of water would drop significantly
from 100 degrees
all of earth's water would start boiling
away like a forgotten kettle
not all of it would turn to vapor soon
we'd reach an equilibrium with enough
vapor to prevent the water from boiling
but with zero atmospheric pressure the
water wouldn't remain liquid what's left
of it would turn into ice
grab a winter coat as it's going to get
pretty chilly without an atmosphere to
trap heat near the surface earth's
temperature would drop to an average of
minus 18 degrees and temperatures would
see extreme shifts between day and night
now slather on the sunscreen because
even with temperatures that low you can
still get sunburn without the atmosphere
to filter solar radiation sunbathing
would become lethal
but would you even survive that long
only if you had a pressure suit and an
oxygen mask on without those two things
you're no longer with us
in order to inhale your diaphragm uses
the pressure difference between the air
inside your lungs and the air outside of
your body without outside pressure you
wouldn't be able to breathe even if
you're hooked up to our respirator
but don't hold your breath your lungs
would pop in a matter of seconds
exhaling would help your body stay alive
for about three minutes but you'd be
unconscious after just 15 seconds
everything that needs oxygen would die
all animals all plants that includes
everything in the oceans too but there'd
still be some bacteria left maybe it
would evolve into something intelligent
eventually solar radiation would break
the water vapor down into oxygen combine
that with the carbon dioxide pumped for
volcanoes and from geothermal vents and
it would create a new atmosphere
but this would be long after humans were
gone and too thin for us to breathe
anyway
now take a deep breath because you can
and relax
no massive meteor or coronal ejection is
likely to strip away our atmosphere
anytime soon
and from now on try to appreciate every
sunset you see if we end up fleeing this
planet to colonize mars they won't look
this beautiful
you